Mister President,
the main purpose of my interest today
is to place before this Assembly a proposal
which if accepted
could make a positive and far reaching
contribution to the cause of peace.
I propose that the Indian Ocean
be declared a zone of peace.
The item has been inscribed on the agenda
of this session as an important and urgent one.
The proposal is not a completely new one.
The concept of a zone of peace in
is inherent in the concept of non alignment,
which requires that the land territories,
the US space
and territorial waters of non aligned states
must be closed to Great Park conflicts and rivalries.
All areas under the jurisdiction of non aligned States
should therefore be definition
by definition be zones of peace.